نتابع هذه الصور لعمليه انقاذ لامراه
امراه وطفلين في انطاكيا في هذا اليوم
العاشر اذا صور من انطاكيا وهي ايضا واحده
من المدن اتضررت بشكل كبير في الجانب
التركي اذا انقاذ امراه
وطفلين ونشاهد هذه الصور
لعمليه الانقاذ والفرحه باديه على وجوه
المنقذين اذا امراه وطفلين في اليوم
العاشر من عمليات البحث عن من لا زالوا
على قيد الحياه رغم تراجع الامل في وجود
احياء بمرور الساعات ومرور الايام اذا هذا
واحد من الناجين
اذا نذكر ايضا انه هو في منطقه كهرمان
مراش ايضا تم انقاذ
سيده في السابعه والسبع من عمر وقبلها
سيده اخرى كانت في الاربعينيات من العمر
وفي هذه اللحظات ننقل هذه الصور
لانقاذ هذه السيده وطفلين لسنا ندري ان
كان الطفلان هم طفله هذه السيده ام وجد في
نفس المكان او تم اخراجهم من نفس المكان
هذه الصور اذا من انطاكيا